a 77-year-old man had enough of climate
activists in Panama blocking the road so
he did what probably many people want to
do in these situations and shot two of
them dead for his actions Kenneth
Darlington was not only arrested but has
gone viral to the implicit and explicit
cheers of many conservatives who are
rightly frustrated by climate activists
Shenanigans such as shutting down
roadways preventing parents from taking
their children to the hospital even and
attacking Priceless art but of course
darlington's vigilantism is not actually
Justified you don't just get to shoot
people for inconveniencing you no matter
how annoying they are and yet
darlington's actions are entirely to be
expected authorities in Panama and
around the world regularly refuse to
enforce the law when leftists break it
and when the legitimate Authority
refuses to do its job things like this
always happen
always necessarily because of a fact
that I have observed for some years now
which is that there will be order order
can be enforced by the police order can
be enforced by the Civil Authority or
order can be enforced by an old man
civilian with a gun who's had
enough but Society will not tolerate
chaos for long so the question is what
kind of order will we have I'm Michael
nois
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode is brought to you by good
ranchers claim your year of free meat 15
bucks off and free shipping with my code
NES KW as at goodranchers.com that is
goodranchers.com promo code nolles
today Marsha
Blackburn is going to subpoena the
Epstein Client List we'll get to that in
just a moment also the father of Indie
Gregory this this poor British baby that
the British government is trying to kill
uh might be able to come on the show uh
the only reason he would not be able to
come on the show is if he has to be in
court for a last minute plea to stop the
British government from killing his
child uh so stay tuned for that first
though before we move on speaking of
killing this guy Kenneth Darlington he's
gone viral that picture of him holding
holding the gun out casing just flying
right by his head he's just had
enough it's gone totally viral it's it's
considered one of the hardest pictures
ever taken probably and yet while people
feel that they're really rooting for
this guy obviously it's vigilantism this
is not really Justified nobody was
trying to rush their child to the
hospital hospital or anything like that
the climate activists are extremely
annoying and breaking the law but it
doesn't necessarily give you the right
to shoot them the the second observation
I had about this whole Fiasco is nobody
really knows anything about this
situation a lot of people see this
picture they assume it happened in
America or in Europe it didn't it
happened in Panama they assume it's
exactly the same group that's protesting
the van go paintings just stop oil and
and throwing soup on Priceless artwork
but it's not this this has not just been
going on for a day or two days in Panama
it's been going on for weeks and the
protest is over a a new Panamanian
policy for copper mining so so the
environmental activists are
protesting the the large mining contract
that will allow a canada-based firm
first Quantum minerals to operate the
largest pit copper mine ever in the
region for at least 20 years and so all
of a sudden now the protests seem less
like some weird weirdo purple-haired
hippie chick trying to shut down traffic
and and more a legitimate Act of Civil
Disobedience and and a political protest
against corruption even more than
against Environmental Policy uh the
roadblocks by the way have not just
inconvenienced drivers they've caused up
to $80 million in Daily losses to
businesses they've shut schools down for
more than a week
so whether
you deep down support this guy who shot
the activists or whether you think no
this is really bad maybe I'm even on the
activist side to me the most important
observation here is how quickly we see a
picture on the internet and we just jump
to a conclusion without knowing anything
in this case anything about the
interaction between these two groups but
also anything about Panama anything
about this government policy we don't
know any of it at all it reminds me of a
great Tucker Carlson text that came up
during that Dominion lawsuit against Fox
News which is Tucker said I'm so tuned
into the internet that I see some video
of a right-winger beating up a leftwing
or or or vice versa and I just feel I I
I salivate you know I just feel so
excited by it and I and he said and
that's a bad feeling to have I shouldn't
do that it it's almost like a type of
pornography it's not sexual but it RI it
doesn't rile up your lust but it rils up
your anger it rils up your wrath it rils
up your pride it rils up whatever we
don't we don't know anything about
it an image is worth a thousand words
and then we fill in those thousand words
with whatever preconceived notion we
already had floating around our heads
has nothing to do with the situation in
Panama speaking of Law and
Order seven Nashville police officers
have just been placed on leave over the
shooter Manifesto leaks you know there
was the shooting
the identifying gal who slaughtered
those poor little kids at the Christian
School at Covenant School in Nashville
then we didn't hear the manifesto for
weeks and weeks months and months even
though in all of these shootings
whenever it's a white guy if the white
guy especially is a little right wing
the manifesto leaks immediately here we
didn't get anything and then Crowder
Steven Crowder and his team were able to
get a leak of the manifesto we saw wait
I don't even see a ton of pro stuff in
here it's largely anti-white rhetoric
very leftwing rhetoric but but
specifically anti-white even though the
the shooter was white and we only saw
three pages of the leak there there's
obviously more to the manifesto so what
does the Nashville Police Department do
do they go and they say okay we're going
to release the rest of the manifesto do
they go
and shed any light on this horrific
shooting in Nashville no they they Place
seven cops on leave which tells
me this whole Manifesto is likely much
much worse the moment that the manifesto
leaked you saw leftwing journalists say
these were taken out of context and this
is a selective leak even the authorities
this is a selective leak to paint a
political picture oh you don't like a
selective leak then release the whole
thing well uh no we don't oh why if it's
if it's a selective leak that paints a
dis dishonest deceptive picture of the
shooter then release the whole thing and
then we'll have the we'll have the full
picture well no we don't want to do that
why because the full
Manifesto almost certainly is even worse
for the political left that's why they
want to cover this up now speaking of
demoniacs there a really troubling video
that just came out it's it's troubling
because it sheds light on evil things
that go on in our world that we want to
deny but I kind of like the video in
that it sheds light on evil things that
go on in our world that that a lot of
people want to deny this is of a witch
describing how she performs Satanic
rituals
through her abortions how to practice
abortion as a magical ritual part one my
qualifications for teaching this I am a
witch who has had abortions and has used
them as rituals I've been through this
twice and it's birthing magic and death
magic simultaneously if you are a womb
body who has made the decision to have
an abortion keep in mind that there is
death and there is life there has been a
conception there is life that has been
conceived for me I look at the abortions
I've had as workings so just like you
would go through a spell and do things
in a very specific order you would you
would lay things out in a very specific
order because how we do our rituals and
our workings and our spell castings the
order that we do them in is the order
they play out in in the physical when
the magic like really kicks in and our
spirits that we've called on say it's
time for that working to work so if we
look at an abortion and conception
ritualistically there's a life that has
been
conceived So This Witch is willing to
admit something that most mainstream
liberals will not admit most
pro-abortion regular old liberals will
not admit namely that abortion obviously
ends a life it wouldn't be abortion
otherwise and she says further that the
abortion is not merely a physical action
because we're not merely physical beings
it's a spiritual action and this witch
who does witch stuff who worships and
communes with demons at least in her own
mind she thinks she's doing that she
says obviously the power of life and
death is used in a
ritual and people are going to listen to
this and they're to say man these these
young people they're really into some
weird stuff this new age weird hippie
dippy this is crazy but it's not new
this isn't is n new at all this has been
going on for all of human
history the thing that is new is denying
that this exists for all of human
history everywhere on Earth women like
that have called themselves witches and
killed their babies and believed that
they were communing with demons and
believed that blood sacrifices had a
spiritual consequence to them
particularly Visa the worshipping and
communing with demons and now we in
modern secular liberal Society we say oh
that's all totally crazy and yet the
people who are the most liberal in our
liberal Society the people who are the
most modern liberated feminist all the
isms that we exalt in our modern liberal
Society they agree with the old view
they agree that there are such things as
witches there are such things as demons
that the physical world has a connection
to to the metaphysical World there is
such a thing as sacrifice including
blood sacrifice including human
sacrifice for goodness sakes this rapper
Young Thug who I guess is is on trial
for murder his accomplice when his
accomplice was arrested his accomplice
was arrested performing a Satanic ritual
with a goat sacrificing a goat and
there's now a big legal fight over
whether or not that evidence can be
admitted to the court because the
defense is arguing that that would
Prejudice the jury yeah I think Satanic
rituals might Prejudice the jury this
woman though is is shedding light on
something that we all seem to have
forgotten so and so my question I
remember one time I was interviewing a
Fox News host on on radio when he was
promoting a book and the book was about
Witch Trials you know he said we there's
a political Witch Hunt going on today
and his pitch for the book was well the
first thing about witch hunts that we
need to remember is there's no such
things as
witches I said no of course there are
witches at least I said that in my head
I let him get his book pitch out but
that's what I said to myself I said no
of course there which is more likely
which is more
likely
that everyone for all of human history
until about I don't know 50 or 100 years
ago in specifically in the west that
everyone for all of human history people
who believed in witches and devils and
demons and more importantly who believed
in God and angels and Grace everyone for
all of human history everywhere on Earth
other than us recently they were totally
wrong and we just happened to be
right or vice versa who do you think is
is more diluted this witchy lady talking
about how she sacrificed her children to
the devil or the purple-haired feminist
atheist Marching In the Street saying my
body my choice a pregnancy is not alive
I'm not this is a just a health care
procedure and a a human is just a clump
of cells who do you think is more likely
to be correct we got to talk about these
things when you want to talk you got to
check out P talk right now go to PE
talk.com today is Veterans Day our
friends over at P talk have been working
toward alleviating $10 million and
Veteran debt thanks to your support they
are over 90% to that goal today think
about this the US military is made up of
100% volunteers these are men and women
who willingly sacrifice everything they
have for this country when they are done
serving they return home to a tight job
market and outrageous living expenses
that is why I am so happy that a private
company like P talk has jumped into help
when you switch to P talks Lightning
Fast 5G Network they will donate a
portion of every new order to this noble
cause you can make a real difference
just by choosing Superior cell phone
service P talks plans start at just 20
bucks a month offering unlimited talk
text more data and a mobile hotspot just
go to P talk.com kW to make the switch
let's rally together let's show our
unwavering support for our veterans
visit PE talk.com kwes switch to Pur
talk today it's the right move it is the
American way P
talk.com if you want to hear more on
witchcraft which very much does still
exist you can check out uh my very long
form interview with the former witch
which is now available on YouTube under
Michael and the former
witch speaking of mistreating children
big news out of The Simpsons did you
know that the Simpsons still on the air
The Simpsons the cartoon that started in
1989 I believe has been on for 34
seasons and there have been many
cultural memes that have come out of The
Simpsons one of which is Homer Simpsons
strangling his son Bart but
apparently no longer W that's quite a
grip see March strangling the boy has
paid off just kidding I don't do that
anymore times have changed
so it's a little joke about this meme
from The Simpsons but it's actually The
Simpsons telling you something real
about the show and about how the
political correctness has affected the
show Homer doesn't strangle Bart anymore
used to be whenever Bart would do
something bad and we to go strangle him
like but now they don't do
that we no longer joke about strangling
our kids in society now back 30 years
ago when The Simpsons had or 20 years
ago or 15 years ago when Homer would
strangle Bart it's not that it was
culturally accepted to strangle your
children it was a joke it was a joke
about how sometimes your kids get on
your nerves and you just want to ring
their little necks you know but you're
not you don't actually want to do it you
love your kids we're not allowed to even
joke about that
anymore however now we are allowed to uh
castrate our children now we are allowed
to kill our children through abortion 30
years ago in polite company one would
not really defend abortion 30 years ago
when The Simpsons was starting out
making jokes about strangling their kids
even if you supported abortion you you
would probably say look abortion is
obviously an evil thing nobody wants
abortions we all want fewer abortions
but because of of the difficulty and
complexity of this issue abortion ought
to be safe legal and rare that was the
Democrat position it should be rare
because of how awful it is but you know
we should tolerate it that that was the
whole debate now however we're at a
stage where people will say we need to
shout our abortions oh abortions are so
wonderful we need to enshrine in the
Ohio state constitution a right to kill
babies up until the moment of birth oh a
baby's not even a baby no it's just a
clump of Sals it's a product of
pregnancy it's not no it's good it's an
affirmative good shout your
abortion I I think there might be a
relationship
here as Society gets more
finicky as Society gets a little more
precious about the things we're allowed
to joke about we seem to become more
baric in the things that we're allowed
to
do maybe that's why we can't joke about
it anymore it's too
real the fact that
we with with the affirmation of our
society all the way up to and including
the president of the United States now
celebrate castrating our children
mutilating our children reducing our
children's life expectancy killing our
children even now that we actually do
that may maybe maybe it's that the jokes
are too real maybe we don't we don't cut
out the jokes because we've come a
Kindler gentler Society maybe we cut out
the jokes for precisely the opposite
reason now speaking of
minors my Senator here in the state of
Tennessee the great Maria
Blackburn has just announced something
that I think a lot of not just
conservatives normal people have been
waiting for for for years and that
is she's going to try to get the Epstein
Client List since we're in the business
of issuing subpoenas now here are a few
more that I filed a subpoena to Jeffrey
Epstein's estate to provide the flight
logs for his private plane given the
numerous allegations of human
trafficking and a sexual abuse
surrounding Mr EP
I think it is very important that we
identify everybody that was on that
plane and how many trips they took on
that plane and the destinations to which
they
arrived of course that's great love that
Marsh is doing this one of the great
senators in Washington
DC why has this taken so long can you
believe this I remember the Jeffrey
Epstein story
from
2015 2014 maybe I've been hearing about
Jeffrey
Epstein he was still a free man at that
point then finally they arrest him then
what H oh then whoopsy Daisy the jail
camera went out and a mustachioed
Hillary Clinton showed up and rang his
Little Neck speaking of ringing one's
Little Neck and then we just never heard
anything the Department of Justice has
spent the last couple of years trying to
spy on Catholic
churches uh arresting pro-life parents
of six and seven for peacefully
demonstrating outside of abortion
clinics and exposing the horrors of
abortion have uh called parents akin to
domestic terrorists for wanting to have
some say over their kids' curriculum not
have their kids be taught weird groomer
porno stuff in in Elementary School
classrooms doj's been really focused on
that where's the Epstein Client List how
is it that gilain Maxwell Epstein's uh
intelligence connected business
partner went on trial was obviously
arrested and yet we still do we have one
name
confirmed we know some of the people who
were on the plane but do we have confirm
do we have
it no I frankly I I want the Epstein
Client List move to the top of the list
to me that's more important than Hunter
Biden it's more important than
impeaching Joe Biden I want to know who
in our public life is so
compromised now one thing you don't need
to compromise on is your education if
you check out Hillsdale right now go to
hillsdale.edu are you a few years or
decades out of school and wondering what
did I learn what was the point you might
even be thinking I don't have the time
to learn something new if that's you
you're not alone it's not too late
Hillsdale College is offering more than
40 free online courses learn about the
works of CS Lewis the rise and fall of
the Roman Republic or the hist history
of the ancient Christian church with
Hillsdale colleges online courses if you
are not sure where to start check out CS
Lewis on Christianity in this seven
lecture course you will examine some of
Lewis's classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you'll also see
what LS had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever and roll now
and CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life
go to hillsdale.edu
canw to enroll there's no cost it's easy
to get started hillsdale.edu
hillsdale.edu
noes my favorite comment yesterday is
from the chicken Lord 9617 who says
can't wait for Michael's favorite
comment to be one of the many saying
nolles is wrong vake crushed it
completely well hold
on I I think I pointed that out I think
I said immediately the gave the most
brilliant performance of the debate
he had a little bit of a low point when
he took a hit on Nikki Haley for her
daughter using Tik Tock because Nikki
was then able to turn that around and
say stop attacking my daughter then she
made some comment about her high heels
being ammunition or something like that
but and then the the V supporters could
come back and say well hold on Nikki
haly's daughter is not she's not 10
years old she's 25 years old she's an
adult she's but still that was a little
but the reason that anyone is even
talking about V is because and the
reason he has occas Al a misstep but he
has a lot of home runs too is because
he's the only one taking any risks in
the whole race V is the only person
taking any risks at all but I think
that's also the reason that I would
probably score DeSantis is having one I
don't think it's I I also said I don't
think anything is going to move the
polls really at all not in any
significant way but I think DeSantis
gave the kind of performance that Joe
Biden gave during the debates in 2020
which which is not the most brilliant
not the most exciting but just totally
serviceable very competent mainstream
answers succinct to the point so the
only difference there is in 2020 the
Democrat debates mattered they were
consequential for who got the nomination
in this case the Republican front runner
who's leading by what 44 points between
44 and 56 points taking into account
everyone on that stage he was n there so
you know the undercard is is competing
it would seem for something else we now
have to get to my guest I'm very pleased
to hear uh that the father of Indie
Gregory this poor child who is uh facing
death because the British government is
uh attempting to kill the child even
contrary to what the government of Italy
and what the Vatican are offering which
is citizenship and treatment at the
hospital bino Jesu uh we have him on the
line he's not in court right now this
should be an international Scandal but
because we've heard this story now every
six months at least every year
specifically out of the United Kingdom
we've become callous to it and the story
is that a baby faces medical problems
and the parents of the baby want to to
treat the baby and want to help the baby
and want to keep the baby alive and the
Psychopaths running the UK government
and health system and more broadly who
run the health systems in the west want
to kill the child because they now view
death as
treatment Mr Gregory thank you for
coming on the show thank you thank you
for f me so sorry about everything
you're going through it's horrific the
the health problems of your child are
obviously horrific in themselves I I
pray to God I never have to go through
anything like that I it's it's uh the
greatest fear any parent has and then on
top of that
your
government will not permit you to treat
your child or keep your child alive and
on top of that the UK government will
not
allow the government of Italy which gave
your child citizenship will not allow
the pope will not allow the Vicor of
Christ on Earth to help treat your child
they simply want to kill your baby
yeah tell us what's what's happening
we're just absolutely disgusted um I'm
embarrassed to be British at a minute
you've got another country offering to
pay for the treatment and they're
blocking her from going to Italy they're
blocking her to for coming home to get
exibition they're just being it's just
so cruel and inhumane we just don't
understand where does the case stand now
I know I I really appreciate your making
time I know you've got a lot of other
things on in your mind I I know that
there was a chance you were going to be
in court this morning or this afternoon
by by your time so where where does it
all
stand there's a court heing going off
now it's online virtual I've just had to
pop out to get my daughter from school
and then go back to the hospital and
then join again but yeah the the appeal
is this appeal is to do with where Indie
they're trying to block Indie from
coming home the trying to say she can
only go to a hospice or the hospital to
have a treatment withdrawn so the
blocked us from going it there and now
they're trying to block us from taking
it home it's just
cruel is there any is there any hope at
this point that you will be able to
bring your baby to Italy for treatment
at the Bambino jzu hospital or is that
completely off the table I know the
Italians are doing as much as they can
in the background and we're just hoping
that something will come of it like at
any point it's it's for the UK
government and the Italian government to
come to some sort of agreement that's
what we're hoping
for now short of that you you'd like to
take your daughter home of course you
know you don't want to ship your
daughter off to a hospice to to just be
neglected officially neglected by the UK
medical system so what is their argument
why won't they allow you to take your
own daughter home if if you know things
are going to go south as I suppose they
will for all of us eventually but if you
know if this is really her time but why
why won't they let her have her
her final moments in her home with her
family who who love her rather than in
some clinical U UK
institution it was it was in the
original court order that she could we
could choose for her to come home I
think when the fans out about Italy I
think they got scared and are trying to
block us from taking home because
they're probably scared that we're going
to jump on a on a plane or something and
go go over there that's what it feels
like of course I actually I should have
realized that I because I couldn't
figure out I said it's just seems so
needlessly cruel to say you can't even
take your own daughter home if she is
going to die you're not you can't but
right because they don't want you to
flee to flee to go get medical treatment
from Italy and the and the pope from
from the Vatican though now your
daughter is officially an Italian
citizen do I have that right yeah yeah
that's right yeah
exactly as a parent in the UK you've got
when when you go to the courts you've
got no rights you've set to fail
everybody's against you my daughter's
not brain dead she's moving she's
breathing she's she's alert she there's
children in America with the same
disease who was nine um I've been
talking to the parents of them it's just
it's all down to money it's all down to
cost and resources in the
UK so that that's what this is it's it's
not that you know your your daughter
would would
just die IM immediately or anything like
that it's not what they're saying which
is that oh she's in this horrific kind
of pain and it's whatever youth in Asia
quote unquote arguments that they make
it's it's rather that this is It's a
socialist healthc care system they've
got a finite amount of money and they
just they just don't want to spend the
money to keep your daughter alive I
don't think she's worth the cost because
she's potentially got a shorter life but
nobody knows when they're going to pass
away so they're not God they shouldn't
play this they shouldn't play God this I
I I first covered the story on the show
yesterday and and the the thing that
makes
me it's not the thing that makes me
angriest is what they're doing to your
daughter the thing that makes me second
angriest is that I see what they're
think I see what the judge is thinking I
see what the UK government is thinking I
see their logic the problem is their
premises are wrong and the premises are
wrong for exactly the reason you just
said because they're saying well look
she's going to die eventually yeah
you're going to die eventually too I'm
going to die eventually too you don't
know when you're going to die you maybe
you'll die in 50 years maybe you'll go
get hit by a bus tomorrow does that mean
that we're going to stop feeding you
today does that mean that we're going to
stop giving you basic medical care it's
just so it's just a culture of death
that is so shocking that when it
happened the first couple of times it
was an international Scandal now the
biggest Scandal is that it's not an
international Scandal that not nearly
enough people are talking about this
egregious Injustice that your government
a supposedly civilized government is
doing to you and your family and your
daughter I know it's disgraceful it's
like everyone in the UK is just not
aware of what's happening around him and
you you've got another country Italy who
are doing everything they can and India
wasn't even Italian she's got an Italian
C citizenship now but that country is
doing everything they can to help so why
can't my country help why can't they
come to some sort of
agreements why can't my country help why
can't my country help my own daughter
can you imagine that that is that is
such that phrase is such an indictment
of what is happened to the the medical
system and the whole political order in
these countries uh I I know that you're
uh extremely busy Mr Gregory so I'm
going to let you go and I know that
there you know sometimes we say if if
there's a a real uh important
International cause we say well how can
we help where can we donate I know that
what we're talking about here is a
matter of hours or days the kind of
urgency so of course I encourage
everyone to uh pray for you and your
family and for your daughter that there
is
a happy conclusion you know e even as
unlikely as that seems right now a
priest friend of mine a British priest
friend of mine pointed out once that
prayer is not the last resort prayer is
the first Resort and so we will all
absolutely be praying for you um if
there is if there's any other way that
we can help uh you know please do please
do let us know right thank you cheers
thank thank you Mr Gregory there's a
report out now that the leaders of
Hamas are living in Qatar we all know
that they're not living in Gaza they're
not living in the West Bank they're
living in Qatar which is a very wealthy
Arabian country and their combined worth
seems to be 11
billion which is a lot of money even in
Qatar Qatar is an expensive expensive
country but 11 billion goes pretty far
away there as
well which reminds me that there are
really bad incentives in this war in the
Middle East the leaders of Hamas have no
incentive to compromise and protect
innocent people in in Gaza I am not one
of those on the right and there are many
of them but I'm not one of those calling
for just completely glassing Gaza or
completely running rough shot over the
Palestinian territories I don't think
that would be good I don't think that's
Justified according to just War Theory
but likewise I don't really see how you
give this the people of Gaza a nation
state how do you do that they're run by
Hamas and H Hamas doesn't want a nation
state that's going to end the
grift Hamas is making the leaders of
Hamas just the handful of leaders of
Hamas three of them are worth 11 billion
in their living in luxury in Qatar why
they don't they don't want to go back to
Gaza they don't they don't want to go
anywhere near there and the moment that
the fight is over they lose their money
you even see this a little bit I I'll
bring it to the home front with pro-life
activism when the roie Wade license to
abortion was overruled in DOS I jumped
for Joy I didn't think it would happen
in my lifetime I was so excited a lot of
pro-lifers were very very excited but I
think there were a lot of Republican
politicians who were not excited I bet
there were even Republican politicians
who called themselves pro-life who were
upset at the dobs decision because back
when roie Wade was the law of the
land the Republican politicians could
say we're totally pro-life but there's
nothing we can do but we're listen we
got to work to get roie way overruled so
you got to give us a lot of money that's
right just donate now another $10
million and we'll probably overrule roie
Wade and then it never happened for 49
years it never they got to raise a lot
of money they got to seem like they had
real moral High Ground they didn't have
to do any actual
work and then the Dos decision comes
down all of a
sudden they're not getting all that
money
anymore all of a sudden the pro-life
gravy train gets cut off for some of
those Republican politicians and then
for them now they actually have to take
a stand now they actually have to vote
on pro-life legislation in some cases
now they actually have to articulate a
defense of life now they oo yikes that
could really that might even hurt their
donations further with some of the
moderates and the really they're just
squishes and liberals o yikes real
perverse incentives I think by the way
that that Dynamic of perverse incentives
might help explain why the conservatives
have fumbled on a lot of these recent
referenda on the abortion issue and and
they've just let the left run run with
the
issue because I don't think it's just
that public opinion suddenly changed and
everyone supports abortion can't help
but notice these pro-abortion referenda
were written in a really calculated way
that was persuasive even to some people
in the middle and use language that
conservatives love like small government
and freedom and personal choice and all
the rest of it and pro the pro-life
Conservative Republican politicians were
basically know where to be
found they've got to get their sea legs
again they haven't had to actually fight
on this issue the the activists on the
ground have and a handful of elected
Republicans have but the ones who just
kind of check the box oh yeah I'm
pro-life yeah give me your checks Pro
lifers yeah I'm I'm sure I'm pro- life
they haven't had to actually fight on
the issue in almost 50 years and now I'm
very excited to say finally finally we
arrive at my favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag the mailbag is sponsored by P
talk peer talk.com KW today hey Smoky
Mike here's a little story for you three
of the world's greatest Spies all get
caught at the exact same time one French
the other English and the last Italian
the Frenchman has his hands tied and is
taken away to be tortured he lasts 2
hours before he cracks and is taken back
to the cell next the Englishman has his
hands tied and is taken away to be
tortured he lasted for 4 hours before
giving a
Secrets lastly the Italian has his hands
tied and is taken away to be tortured he
lasts for 11 hours until the torturer
gives up when he gets back to the hotel
the Frenchman and the Englishman ask him
how did you last so long he said I
wanted to give up after 10 minutes but I
couldn't get my hands
unstuck you know I could see that coming
a mile away could see coming a mile away
but I like it and I might have to use
that joke in the future next one Hey
Dirty Mike Bryson was taken here and I I
regret to inform you that my name is
still taken I need you to put on your
nomus cap for my question let's say the
betting odds are correct and Trump is
the nominee given that Ron de santz
cannot run for governor again what do
you think his political future looks
like I can't imagine he plans to go
gently into that good night after his
term is over given that Florida is
already quite red in DC I can't see him
running for house or Senate does he fall
in line behind Trump after dropping out
and hope for a cabinet position should
Trump win I do think Trump's dieh hard
support ERS will soften on him similarly
to Cruz after the 2016 election do you
think there's an Avenue for him to
capture the Republican Party in the
future what's the pathway for that
anyway thanks for answering my question
love the
show yes I think there is a future for
Ronda santz I don't
think that people hate Ronda santis I
think there are a lot of people like me
who really like Donald Trump and really
like Ronda santz I I I I know that
that's not represented in the media all
that I might be the only person with the
show who's saying that but I think
that's a lot of people and they'll say
either oh I really like Trump but I'm
I'm rooting for disantis now or they'll
say look I like Trump Trump's the man
he's running he he can get these things
done and Ron is good too but he needs a
little time to cook and he'll he'll have
his turn also and I think uh you know if
if uh the relationship between Trump and
Cruz
could be
rehabilitated I think the relationship
between Trump and disantis could too I
don't think it's personal with
disantis you you know it's like that
line uh from The
Godfather when when uh Michael Corone
says he wants to go shoot the cop that
beat him up and Tom Hagen and sunny the
brother they're laughing at him they say
oh you getting all riled up he says it's
not it's not personal it's not personal
sunny it's only business it's only
business sunny I think that's the same
thing here with with Trump and
DeSantis I think it's business and then
it could move on uh I could see DeSantis
maybe running for US Senate maybe I
could see him going into Private
Industry for a little while and then
coming back and running again later
though that would be a little bit
tougher but look he's a bulldog and he's
very good and his views represent more
the future of the Republican party than
do the views of the squishes in the libs
so I think he's got a pretty pretty
bright future even though he's taken on
Trump next one dear Michael according to
Catholic Doctrine can non-catholic
Christians go to heaven I haven't been
able to find a straightforward answer to
this online thank you so
much there there is about a 10-hour
answer to this that still would probably
be unsatisfactory uh the operative term
here the operative phrase in Catholicism
is extra ecclesium nula salus outside of
the church there is no salvation which
uh has been interpreted for some time
now to mean not not exactly that if you
are not a
professing practicing Catholic that you
have absolutely no hope of salvation but
rather that without the that that
salvation comes through the church and
from the church but that we can we can
hope and I certainly do pray I have I
have relatives and friends and loved
ones who are not uh explicitly Catholic
and uh I I pray for them and I pray for
God's extraordinary Mercy um there there
was a view called sometimes called phism
or the Boston heresy that uh took a much
narrower reading of extra clam nulas
salus that
was that some would argue was condemned
as a heresy by the Vatican though it's
that's also a complicated issue um so
what is the upshot that I would suggest
I would suggest that we pray in Earnest
for our friends and loved
ones uh for God's extraordinary mercy
and for their salvation but I would
recommend if it's it's if it's your own
life that you're talking about
here you know I would recommend you
Avail yourself at the sacraments and the
uh Graces afforded uh from our Lord
through his church that's what I would
do okay next one hey Michael I currently
attend the Latin Mass but what with the
restrictions that have come down
recently our Bishop has decided to move
the the mass to a different Parish um
should we switch to The New Parish uh
even though that would mean giving up on
the very strong community that we have
at our current parish and uh or should
we stay at our current Parish where our
pastor has offered to do the novas sordo
ad orientum uh in Latin with incense
chant and all the rest of it um
especially in light of the fact that the
new Parish our Bishop has said we are
not allowed to have any Latin Mass
gatherings or events I appreciate your
thoughts on this thank you H that's a
tricky one you know I love the
traditional Latin mask for those who are
not mackerel snapping papists out there
the traditional Latin mass is not merely
different from the new mass that came
about in the 1960s and70s called the
mass of Paul v 6 um it's not merely
different in that one is Latin one is
English actually what's even more
confusing is the new mass the mass of
Pope Paul v 6 is normatively done in
Latin too but what what the difference
is is that a lot of prayers are removed
very often the priest is facing away
from the Altar and facing toward the
people and there's some hippie stuff
that kind of snuck in and so it's it
just doesn't seem as reverent and it's
not as full and it's not the mass of the
ages that endured basically without
change for 1400 years at least and has
some Roots going back much further even
than that so if it were me I'd probably
go to the Latin Mass the traditional
Latin Mass Parish I've attended many
Reverend novas sordo masses I I'm not
saying that that's not valid or anything
like that I I still attend them
sometimes um great priests who do that
sometimes it's nice to work within the
system to try to try to change it uh and
bring it back to to sanity and reverence
and tradition um you know I I would
defer to your own Prudence there but if
it were me I I guess I'd probably go to
the the tlm pair I just think the
traditional Latin mass is just so
beautiful you know so so incomparably
beautiful and reverent and proper okay
written mailbag question from Joseph hey
Michael I'm in love with a girl who I
want to marry and I'm thinking about
popping the question however there's a
mental block in my mind saying that my
actual soulmate is out there somewhere
in this world this thought has nothing
to do with the girl I'm with now she's
great just comes from my own weird form
of paranoia any advice getting over this
if I'm thinking this way does it mean my
girl isn't the one thanks no look
everyone has doubts in Romance you know
when you're dating even if you you're
with the love of your life you know
before you've made a commitment
especially as you're approaching the
moment where you say am I going to be
with this person for my entire life of
of It's Perfectly Natural especially in
our modern dating culture where people
very often meet later they they meet on
an app or something where you don't
really know the person for so long it's
very common for people to say well is
this really the one I don't know what if
I had swiped left on that person I
swiped right on someone else would that
other person be my soulmate uh so that
that's perfectly normal I would not
worry about that if you are thinking
about an actual other girl if you were
thinking about an actual person and
saying should I marry this girl or that
girl then I would interrogate that
question and come to an answer on
it if you are thinking about an
imaginary girl then I would focus just
on your prospective fiance and say is
there something here that I think is not
going to work am I imagining some other
girl because there is something within
this person that I suspect is just not
conducive to a good life am I only
marrying this person because you know I
just turned such and such age and I just
feel it's time to get
married and if
so how difficult would that be you know
if if the issue is I don't you know I
don't like the way that this person you
know washes the dishes then you can
probably move on if it's I don't like
this habit of virtue or vice and you
know this person is a zarrian and I'm a
presbyterian well that might be a bigger
problem so I would interrogate that but
I I wouldn't let your
your um wondering as a man is there
someone else out there I wouldn't let
that be the reason you don't get married
I mean that's that's totally natural
question is what's driving that from Dan
hi Michael I'm a casual cigar consumer I
went searching for your cigars as soon
as I heard the news my question is how
do you recommend your cigars be consumed
cut or punch v-cut or straight matches
or lighters details Michael please as a
true connoisseur of cigars I seek your
advice I have a pack of five Dawn
robustos arriving soon oh good congratul
I'm glad you were able to get some I
want to enjoy them to the fullest keep
doing the Lord's work thanks what I
would do especially for the dawn rusto
let me see if I have do I have a cutter
on me of course I do of course I do I
would use a v cut I or not a I'm sorry
don't don't listen to that I this kind
of looks like a V but this is a gutin
cut there you go just a
little I would use a double blade
Guillotine cut if I if I were to use any
lighter at all I don't really like
v-cuts all that much sometimes on a
torpedo you can use a v-cut it's not my
favorite even on a torpedo cigar I
usually use a straight cut I don't
really use punches all that much
sometimes if it's a little Corona cigar
I will but if if you have too small of
little punch on too big uh ring gauge
then it's it's going to it's going to
mess up the taste it might be a little
too strong
um the real cigar guys either bite it
off or use their fingers sometimes I use
my finger if I don't have a cut I don't
usually use my teeth but straight cut
and make sure that the cut is smaller
than the ring gauge of the cigar not too
small but you know not people mostly cut
off too much from Colby Dear Mr nolles
one of the biggest value changes I've
come to recognize in life is how Society
values sex now back then sex back then
in the good old days sex was kept sacred
and even if there was prostitution it
wasn't as common today uh as it is with
only fans and pornography access so in
your opinion what do you believe is the
cause of young men falling prey to
pornography like myself and women
turning to online prostitution as a
source of income even if they're married
or mothers was it just the rise of
feminism or the sexual Revolution or
something even deeper than that I feel
like there's a deeper cause to this sad
reality we live in and I wanted to get
your views on the subject at hand hope
your analysis leaves me speechless well
the cause is there many causes thank you
going back many
centuries the cause is theological
liberalism to begin with theological
liberalism which uh loosens up the faith
which has animated our civilization why
is it bad
to uh sleep around why is it bad to not
have sexual morals why is it bad to look
at born why it's bad because because God
says so because the very moral order is
is ordered against it
um that used to inform the state uh even
in private Faith theological liberalism
has created sisms and dissensions and
sects and all sorts of problems that
have led to a a radical skepticism that
says well we can't really know religious
truth there's no real Authority that
could tell us religious truth so that's
the first problem then the theological
liberalism becomes a political
liberalism that suggests all sorts of
crazy things such as uh a firm line of
separation between church and state
whatever that even means
or which suggests that we we can't
legislate morality which is a completely
meaningless statement and and uh it runs
against everything we've ever known
about political philosophy and it
creates a skepticism and a
secularism that leads to the rise of all
sorts of crazy ideologies like feminism
and all the rest of it LGBT ISM and uh
and ultimately a kind of selfishness
that says that the state is not about
the common good and being ordered toward
a good which is conducive to all of our
flourishing but
that the purpose of the state is just to
protect my supposed right to do whatever
I want even if it's disordered and
degenerate so that's a that's a short
answer there's much more to be said on
the subject but rest show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code NES KW has a check out
for two months free on all annual
[Music]
plans